[Musique]
la chronique sport la page sport comme
tous les lundis tous les résultats et
puis également les événements à venir
bonsoir Anthony oui bonsoir wilfriedah
principal événement ce weekend c'est le
ver trail ce ce trail qui commence de
jours et qui est fini de nuit qui qui
est organisé samedi par les élèves du du
lycée mariecurry de versaill dont est
présent ce soir sur le plateau louprigan
qui est élève de secondes au lycée
bonsoir à toi et tu es accompagné d'un
des un de tes professeurs de P
et qui est co-organisateur de
l'événement Fabien comalusier bonsoir à
vous bonsoir et merci de votre accueil
c'est avec plaisir mais juste avant de
de parler un peu de du projet puisque
c'est un projet pédagogique à à vocation
sportive je vous propose de parler de de
tennis de table puisqueà encour on
connaît bien l'équipe féinine qui qui
évolue en probé qu'on suit tout au long
de cette saison mais quelques tables
plus loin s'entraînent désormais les
pongistes and dis sport autour de
Florence cogoso he l'athlète
paralympique que nous avons reçu sur le
plateau à plusieurs reprises qui était
au j de Londres d'ailleurs
ahé une àentière quictionne désorma àin
régime cette saison et j'ai eu la chance
de suivre un de leur raîn il y a
quelques jours il y a encore quelques
mois Florence Sirot devait se sentir
bien seul obligé de s'entraîner avec les
pongistes valides depuis la section
andisport de le CTT a bien grandi et
compte désormais se licenciés tout
commence il y a 2 ans et demi alors
qu'il prépare son diplôme d'entraîneur
Clément Gadea se tourne vers l'athlète
paralympique et le tennis de table en
dis sport entraîneur de joueurs valide
au départ il découvre alors une autre
facette de son métier ce qui va être un
peu différent ça va être l'adaptation au
handicap une personne qui va être
tétraplégique ne pourra pas avoir une
rotation de bassin alors qu'un valide va
pouvoir le faire donc va falloir
s'adapter avec le handicap tiens je peux
pas me déplacer tiens je vais essayer de
bouger un peu plus avec mon bras je peux
pas utiliser mes abdos tiens je vais
essayer de jouer un peu plus avec les
épaules cette approche personnalise très
vite le jeu de chaque joueur un style
basé sur le déplacement pour les joueurs
de petite taille comme le jeune Alexis
d'agent ou plutôt sur l'avant-bras pour
les les joueurs en fauteuil un handicap
assez haut donc je suis je suis
tétrapégique je suis obligé d'attacher
ma raquette sinon je n'aurais pas assez
de force pour pouvoir la tenir longtemps
et être suffisamment précise pour les
placements de balles je la prend en fait
très tôt pour pas après sur la prochaine
balle être en retard désormais bien
encadré ces athlètes s'astraignent à
quatre entraînements par semaine avec
pour objectif les prochains Jeux
paralympiques à Rio en 2016 c'est même
dans la tête c'est pas dans un coin
c'est dans la tête et ma préparation et
par rapport à Rio après je je
décrocherai la sélection ou pas mais en
tout cas c'est l'objectif ce qui me fait
rêver c'est les Jeux paralympiques de
Rio en
2016 et voilà pour cette équipe un
paralympique du côté qui va participer
sans doute au prochain Jos paralympique
ils en ont envie en tout cas on entendu
cette équipe Andy du club de tennis de
table d lancours qu'on suivra bien sûr
régulièrement oui tout à fait mais on va
on va tout d'abord passer au trail ce
trail de nuit donc le ver trail qui est
organisé ce weekend par le lycée marcury
Fabien comment est né ce projet
pédagogique donc ça a commencé dès le
mois de septembre on pourrait même dire
en amont au mois juin lorsqu'on a décidé
d'ouvrir des enseignements d'exploration
en EPS au lycée marcury on a pris un
billet différent on s'est dit on va pas
refaire 2 heures de PS comme d'habitude
on va pas faire un cours que théorique
on s'est dit on va le faire vivre une
expérience à part entière on va
organiser une épreuve sportive grand
public en tout cas on se lance dans le
projet puis si les élèves sont bons et
ben il y aura une course et les élèves
justement ils ont adhéré tout de suite
lou ça t'a plu ce ce C cette idée de de
faire d'organiser complètement un trail
ben oui parce que c'était une nouveauté
et qu'on avait jamais pu faire ça avant
et voilà qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que tu
as découvert dans dans l'organisation de
ce TR peut-être l'organisation d'une
compétition c'est pas juste le jour de
la course il y a plein de choses en
amont bah je pensais pas que ça allait
être aussi long et aussi et qui allait
avoir enfin qu'on allait
devoir voir euh en T les de la
compétition c'est ça et et que c'était
aussi long et Fabien vous me disiez hor
antenne que il y a eu la création du
site internet puisque le le trail est
est mis sur internet que un site que les
élèves ont créé c'est ça just les
opérations à côté oui alors exactement
on a eu une élève en gros c'était une
réunion de départ où
chacun s'est proposé pour les diverses
missions que les élèves ont repéré par
eux-mêmes nous on a noté les idées au
tableau et finalement on s'est retrouvé
avec 10 grandes missions on a eer une
des élèves de la classe qui a fait un
super site web c'est
vertrail.com ça vous fait un petit peu
de pub pour les voir vous retrouvez
toutes les informations dessus tout le
contenu est réalisé par les élèves alors
des moments effectivement on les aide
euh et comme dit loup c'est
effectivement un projet qui était assez
long puisque les élèves ont fait toutes
les démarches administratives eux même
ils se sont ils sont allés contacter les
institutions pour avoir des des des
financements c'est ça des des exactement
donc euh il y a eu plusieurs commissions
mais lou je pense peut peut vous en
parler peut-être un petit peu tu as
participé à quel à quel projet làdessus
justement moi jeis dans un groupe où on
devait aller on devait on devait
s'occuper du budget donc on allé au
Conseil Général des Yvelines à la mairie
donc vous avez dé marchés en fin de
compte pour essayer d'avoir un budget
pour pour la course de samedi ouais
d'accord et alors qui sera de nuit un
trail nocturne pour ceux qui suivent les
indications qui sont affichées à l'écran
trail nocturne qui commence de jours
mais qui dont la la majeur partie se
déroule une fois que le soleil est
couché et que justement ce parcours que
que vous avez mis en place toujours en
collaboration avec les élèves il a des
spécificités oui alors on a pour le coup
là je suis content que lu nous
accompagne aujourd'hui
un papa qui est un grand trailer du coup
on a fait des propositions de chemin aux
élèves on savait que derrière le tout
devait être validé par l'ONF que je
tiens à remercier particulièrement ce
soir puisque grâce à Madame de britau on
a eu l'ensemble des autorisations sans
quoi la course n'aurait pu avoir lieu
donc les élèves choisissaient entre gros
chemin chemin un peu plus petit en
fonction de la réglementation des forê
et plutôt pentu plutôt un peu moins et
je me rappelle loup m'avoir dit
plusieurs fois dans le repérage c'est un
peu trop facile là il pensent déjà il
pensaient au concurrents ils essayent de
mettre un peu de beau malovvrage
exactement donc il y a des il y a des
vrais zone technique avec quelques très
belles descentes qui dit très belle
descente dit très belle montée on a 370
m de dénivelés positif sur le parcours
euh le parcours peut être fait en relais
également euh donc le dénivelé a été
réparti sur les deux blocs de 9 km de
manière assez équitable avant de parler
plus spécifiquement de de ce qu'est le
trail de nuit je vous propose tout
d'abord de de parler de bowlying
Wilfried on change de sujet alors on
change sujet de sujet euh est-ce que
vous pratiquez le le bowlying
fréquemment alors ça ça m'arrive mais
vraiment en amateur hein le score à peu
près 100 r pas dans les détails et bien
au au club au club de plaisir c'est une
des écoles de bowling les plus
importantes hein de la région
d'île-de-fance parce que c'est un sport
aussi c'est un vrai sport c'est c'est un
éternel un éternel débat mais il
revendique que c'est un sport et depuis
quelques mois dans ce sport bah les
Bouleurs de de plaisir trustent tous les
podiums dans les catégories de jeunes du
coup avec elodim moan nous avons voulu
comprendre les raisons de ce succès
on plus ing club de plaisir ou l'usine à
champion sur la piste 1 Angie Grob
l'enfant du club presque élevé une boule
à la main la championne régionale 2012 a
été la toute première licenciée du BCP
sur la piste 2 Chloé pédejint 9 ans
vicechampion des evelines pour une
demoiselle le bowling peut s'avérer être
une activité surprenante surtout pour
ses amis
disent je savais pas que ça se faisait
un sport le bowling avec un record à 223
points Victoria goutorb 17 ans tout
juste affronte déjà les joueurs seior de
cette réussite sur les pistes dépend
beaucoup la complicité entre le joueur
et sa boule une arme qui devient très
vite le prolongement du bras dès que je
vais au bowling je la prends sinon
j'aime pas aller au bowling s parce que
j'y arrive plus à jouer s en fait c'est
quoi c'est la superstition un petit peu
non c'est c'est juste qu'on a l'habitude
et c'est fait à nos doigts donc c'est
sur mesure en fait et contrairement à ce
que l'on pourrait croire la vitesse de
la boule et le Strike ne sont pas
l'obsession des Bouleurs le Strike est
je dirais l' sur le gâteau pour moi le
le jeu pour les jeunes aujourd'hui c'est
d' fait les 10 kill en deux fois et
d'essayer de faire le maximum de Kill
sur une première boule le bowlying n'est
pas un jeu de force mais pas un jeu de
rapideidé donc plus vous êtes calme plus
vous allez être précis plus vous aurez
de performance et les 20 jeunes de
l'école de bowling de plaisir semble
avoir compris cette
philosophie fait une compétition avec
les jeunes là qu'on a vu oui oui
malheureusement je me suis fait battre
je suis pas un expert du du strike ils
ont l'air assez doué ouais tout à fait
ouais tout à fait euh on va revenir au
trail de de ce weekend le vert trail euh
ça a interrogé beaucoup ilfed avant
l'antenne quel quelle est la la
différence entre courir de jour et de
nuit est-ce qu'il y a une perte de
repère oui alors là je effectivement
c'est gros changement la vitesse de
déplacement si on veut aborder d'un
point de vue technique va être plus
lente euh parce que les appuis au sol
sont moins sûrs euh du coup quelqu'un
qui ferait un trail habituellement
plutôt à 13 kmh risque de courir au
moins 1 à 2 km/h moins vite sur
l'ensemble de l'épreuve et surtout la
fatigue va croître de manière
exponentielle parce que il y a le
problème d'acuité visuelle chaque
concurrent est équipé d'une frontale
certains d'une frontale toute simple
comme on le voit sur sur les images là
justement exactement et puis d'autres
ont des frontales très puissantes ça pe
aller d'être la puissance des frontales
peut être multipliée par 10 et du coup
on n pas du tout la même acuité dans les
chemins et ça veut dire qu'on se blesse
aussi plus facilement il y a un risque
de de blessure s moi j' que les appuis
soi moins sûr j'irais pas jusque là je
pense que inconsciemment ou consciemment
d'ailleurs on s'adapte à la vitesse
c'est-à-dire une descente qu'on ferait
de jours peut-être à 20 km/ he dans une
descente caillouteuse on va la passer à
15 à l'URE on ayant l'impression d'être
à 20 km/h c'est ça qui est qui est qui
est assez exceptionnel dans la TRA le
trail nocturne la spécificité comme t'en
parler c'est qu'on va partir de jours
pendant je pense une vingtaine de
minutes pour les surtout c'est ça ou
pour tout le monde puisqu'on part tous
ensemble le comme le disent nos élèves
c'est une course réservée aux amateurs
et aux professionnel euh et
effectivement euh on va dire que
certains vont faire peut-être 4 ou 5 km
de jour tandis que les autres on feront
que de et demi mais ça va être assez
sympa ce moment où on passe du la nuit
on vente ce qu'on appelle le crépuscule
à la lumière par les frontal et là il y
a C ce temps d'adaptation pour pour
l'œil pour la vue entre bah le jour et
puis on passe à la nuit effectivement ça
doit être compliqué à gérer et il y a
aussi l'aspect technique du fait que
tous les concurrents vont peut-être pas
vouloir allumer leur fontal en même
temps et à partir du moment où ça
commence à être allumé l'œil attiré par
ce qui brille c'est plus compliqué le
regard est toujours porté vers le bas
parce qu'on a besoin de contrôler ses
appuis euh la prise d'information pour
suivre le parcours la grosse difficulté
c'est de pas se perdre du coup nos
jeunes organisateurs on vont avoir une
grosse mission tout vendredi soir et
tout samedi c'est de faire un balisage
proche du sol plutôt 1 m mettre des
bâtons lumière et et 18 km à baliser
avec des bout de rubalis tous les 20 m
je pense qu'on va passer il y a du
travail aura plus de monde justement
pour encadrer la sécurité tout au long
de la course par rapport à une course
traditionnelle un trail traditionnel en
plein jour est-ce que vous mettez plus
de monde au bord du alors effectivement
je pense que sur sur le trail de Manil
Hamo où j'ai été concurrent récemment il
y a peu de signaleurs sur le parcours
puisque ces deux jours et c'est très
bien balisé sur un trail nocturne on
peut pas prendre de risque qu'une rue
balise a été coupée parce que on on ne
voit rien
donc on a la chance d'avoir une grosse
main d'œuvre de bénévole c'est toute
l'équipe d'organisation euh ils sont
combien d'ailleurs 36 élèves des élèves
de Seconde 8 et de 2e 7 du lycée
maricury et euh une dizaine de personnes
en permanence dans l'espace d'accueil
qui est la halle d'athlétisme de
Porchefontaine et 25 autres à des points
essentiels sur le parcours en relation
directe par téléphone avec une unité
mobile de premier secours qui sera au
milieu du parcours et sur l'ire d'arrivé
et alors au niveau des inscriptions
c'est complet on peut encore s'inscrire
on peut le faire en relais willf des
mois par exemple donc alors on vous le
dit aujourd'hui avec Lou nous on vous
invite je F la partie de jour et je vous
laisse de nuit exactement à l'heure
actuelle on est à 150 inscrits euh il y
a encore de la place on peut encore
accueillir 100 personnes facilement
jusqu'à samedi dans la mesure du
possible on souhaiterait que les gens
s'inscrivent sur on peut s'inscrire le
mieux c'est de s'inscrire sur Internet
c'est sur le site
vertil.com exactement ver alors pour la
petite histoire ça a été inventé par les
élèves on a eu 25 noms sur le tableau
puis ils ont voté puis ils ont voté et
le vertil en fait a fait l'adhésion dès
le début c'était un mélange de vert
comme la couleur du début de versaill et
puis le motrail d'accord ça veut dire
qu'il faut s'habiller spécifiquement ou
pas aussi faut s'habiller en verre non
rien à voir faut être en zone en tout
cas faut des gilets al les signaleurs
eux onont des gilets réfléchissant ceux
qui font la course pas d'équipement
particulier à prévoir pour participer
non sur 18 km le Tr par définition c'est
une course en autonomie euh on va
essayer de rajouter une petite plusvalue
avec quand même un ravitaillement en eau
à
mi-parcours le il suffit d'être bien
habillé en fonction de la température du
jour mais dans les bois donc ce sera
frais forcément frais hein que ça se
rafraîchi pour Laé du jour je parlais de
relais hein il y a plusieurs formules ce
ce weekend il y a une formule en
individuel et en relais c'est ça on peut
quand même pour les les moins courageux
on peut faire jour et puis nuit à un
autre partenaire effectivement 18 km
seul c'est une des possibilités 2 x 9 km
c'est la 2è et la 3è c'est 4 et5i + 4
et5i + 9 ce qui permet à tout type de
concurrents de Sallier pour faire le
parcours et on trouvait ça plus sympa
d'avoir un seul départ plutôt que trois
courses espacer 16h 17h 18h tout le
monde ferend le même départ mais chacun
fait la dose des kilomètres qui lui
plaît donc rendez-vous à quelle heure
c'est samedi hein samedi ce samedi lou
le retrait des dossards commence à
quelle heure eu vers 15h exactement 15h
à la halle de portefontaine 63 rue
Raymont jusqu'à 17h 17h15 le briefing
quelques minutes après c'est dépque les
lampes fonctionnent bien et pu on on
fait un rappel au concurrents de
sécurité euh il y a une règle en trail
c'est que on doit assistance à tout
coureur qui se blesserait euh voilà on
peut être dans le top 5 s'il y a une
grosse entorse et qu'on est à ce
moment-là à côté de la personne qui se
baisse on va l'accompagner jusqu'au
point suivant où on aura un relais
téléphone pour que les secours puissent
se dé plac merci à tous les deux d'être
venu nous parler de cet événement qui se
déroule donc du côté de Versailles
n'oubliez pas le site internet pour
toutes les informations merci Anthony on
poursuit la chronique sport on va parler
de capoera à présent oui capoera un
sport dont on parle peu finalement mais
qui est très spectaculaire et ce weekend
avait lieu la 10e rencontre
internationale àencour où des maîtres de
d'un peu partout dans le monde venaient
s'affronter et Valérie oribau et Patrick
Jacques de dismude ont suivz les
acrobaties de ces maîtres pour
l'occasion 25 matr ét venu de toute la
France et de divers pays d'Europe pour
la 10è rencontre internationale de
capera à hencour jugé par d'autres
maîtres que leurs instructeurs habituel
chacun participa au stage afin de passer
sa deè ou 3è corde le principe de la
cera c'est que ça se joue qu'on appelle
une roda et cette Roda est conduite par
de la musique et cette musique qui on va
dire propulse l'énergie donc c'est pour
ça que vous avez une énergie qui émane
de ce champ et qui donne envie
d'applaudir de chanter et d'accompagner
les qui sont dans la les figures
totalement improvisées nécessitent
l'écoute de l'autre pour éviter les
coups pas besoin d'être souple la
souplesse sacquier au fil du temps la
maîtrise des acrobaties aussi jusqu'au
dépassement de soi c'est un sport est
une recherche individuelle mais aussi
collective parce que comme vous voyez on
joue dans dans une re et c'est le groupe
qui propulse l'énergie encore une fois
l'énergie les plus petits en ont à
revendre pour eu cétaitier baptêm une
première fois réussie on a commencé ça
cette année on a ouvert le créneau 4 ans
6 ans et on a eu une une belle comment
dire réussite une belle réussite
làdessus parce que on a plein de petits
qui sont venus et qui sont super
dynamiques qui en veulent et c'est
encore mieux de commencer cet â là parce
qu'ils sont complètement comme ils
savent pas à quoi s'attendre ils se
lancent à corps perdu ça c'est bien
passé j'aime bien la
capura j'ai eu le cœur qui battait mais
ça ça c'était bien passé et j'ai eu j'ai
bien aimé l'association Bell horizoné
capoera compte aujourd'hui 70 adhérents
de tous
âges